it touched on this a little bit of for
both of you what are your thoughts on
modern-day animation particularly
cinematic animation well most of most of
the animation nowadays it seems to me
the produced in the United States has
gone over to computer computer graphics
is a style and it looks alright and if
they tell a good story I can sit through
it I certainly love Nemo and tango
very very good up was very very good but
what happens I think as soon as someone
sees a successful picture done in CG
everybody else jumps in to because they
want to make some money too so what
happens is you get sort of a generic
look of the CG which is starting for me
to look like the last one I saw so it
feels kind of like puppets rather than
the animation that I grew up with and I
would rather I would rather see
something that had the human touch in it
a little bit more that one can exist at
the same time the other one exists you
don't have to have one or the other what
I'm hoping is that with dragon slayers
that maybe we can reintroduce what I
think got thrown out certainly in Europe
they still appreciate it there's a lot
of hand-drawn animation that still being
produced around the world but somehow
when the United States are lost in a fog
and don't seem to know that we've thrown
out something very valuable I always ask
myself why did I feel more of a
connection to hand-drawn animation than
CG animation I very much like CG
animation but I felt more of a
connection to hand-drawn they felt very
much I you get a model a good-looking
model and then you move it around you
move the expressions where with
hand-drawn you have to draw them at
every single frame and you have to
convince the person in every single
frame that this thing is alive and you
have to put the work in every single
time there's another thing I think worth
mentioning on this very subject - I know
that CG tries harder and harder and
harder to give more realistic beautiful
look right so there's shadows the
characters are shaded there's all kinds
of things and now somebody is saying how
can we put pores in the skin well why
don't you just hire an actor because if
you keep moving that that fantasy of
that magic of animation towards the
live-action pretty soon I'm not sure you
have animation anymore they
animation has a way of dramatizing
visually in a way that I know no other
medium can do in that moment when the
which goes down those stairs and goes
into that room throws the box and
decides to make herself into a hag ah
that is so powerful and you know
drinking the stuff for the Thunder and
the lightning and changing into this old
woman those are magical moments that I
have not experienced with all of the
wonderful CG that I have an experience I
don't see the same magic there or
something doesn't connect with me
something doesn't touch and it could be
me it could be that you know I'm just
not familiar with what it is they're
doing in the 90s uh after so many these
very successful wonderful films critics
did not seem to respond as strongly as
with the films are coming out like troll
in Central Park pebble and the penguin
as they did with the earlier work in
both of your opinion what do you feel
changed in that time was it the style or
was it the audience that was us there
was asked you know what if when we did
NIM we had no hands on us we we were the
ones hands on that americantale we
pretty much had all Stephen asked for he
wanted to approve the script and improve
the storyboards but once we got with
other financed ears we suddenly had some
some chefs in the kitchen it didn't
shouldn't have been there and they would
demand that we make changes and make it
simpler and more dumbed down there was
another thing though really really
script is everything and you know that
already but if you don't have a good
script you know you're not going to fix
it you can draw your fingers off if you
want it's just not going to fix it so a
lot of times we would hire writer
we hired a writer who worked on I think
it was a movie called witness we hired a
writer we thought well he there's names
up on the screen he must be really good
that's a great movie he got off the
airplane in Dublin Ireland carrying his
Oscar and I knew we were in trouble we
tried and tried with all dogs go to
heaven to come up with something and we
tried and tried didn't happen until
Robert Towne said what did you guys do
and said we're working on the story and
we don't know how to solve it and he
came up he says okay tell me your story
and you got to do it in five minutes and
so we tried he said where's that where's
that urine
oh yeah too many angels you got too much
heaven in here he says get all that out
he says make it just a dog story a
simple one you'll find that everything
will go just fine we hired someone to do
Thumbelina right she came in and she
wrote and wrote and wrote and wrote and
used up all the time for writing the
script and the script was not very good
I said well okay I'll write the script
we've got foreign employees and they've
got animate so I had a week to write the
script you can't write a script in a
week and so we kept getting in that same
position where we were trying to hurry
hurry hurry get work for the for the
staff and the picture suffers when you
do that had we still made more movies
with Steven Spielberg I think for sure
he would insisted that a good script
happened before we ever started I've
heard over and over Spielberg you know
on top of being a great director is a
phenomenal producer because he allows
for so much freedom so you experienced
something very similar did he sort of
leave you guys alone and then picked up
the pieces where they needed to be
picked up that's what exactly what he
does he's very very good at it and he
has an eye for what will entertain you
know some people they just know they
intuitively know and he seems to have
that will showing the boards and you'll
say well right here what if you did this
this this and this you go oh yeah why
didn't I think if that's a good idea
well now you have this project coming up
that is gonna be in your control this
Dragon's Lair movie that you've gotten
or still in the process again
crowdfunded what can you tell us about
it so far I can tell you right now that
I'm not sleeping very well at night and
I have what some people would call
nightmares I just called them pleasant
dreams which ideas come to the the brain
and then I keep a pad by the side of my
bed and I jot down notes things like
that so I'm already thinking about this
movie and I have to put in my head
really really strong that we're going to
make this movie ideas are happening and
I've got about know five six pages of a
treatment written so far it's not going
to be an expansion of that game we're
not going to do a movie going through
that game but we're going to get to know
who these characters are where that came
from how they get together what their
what do they want each of those
characters have to have some background
and to get the audience to invest to
invest in in them are they going to have
the traditional designs I think of being
the traditional clothes is Dirk and I
have the orange and the yellow and the
hat and everything we got to do that I
mean Dirk's going to have that tunic on
then you know the yellow and the orange
and everything you're gonna have to see
that that's kind of iconic in my mind
you'll see Daphne and probably much more
than you saw in the game you'll have to
be surprised on this one because the
ideas are still coming in and you guys
can write in tell us what you'd like to
see how we'll open minded we got
somebody that can read those right yes
people watching at home you can still
donate we'll put a link in the
description so definitely check that out
um I like to end every interview with uh
two questions that are polar opposites
the first one being whether it be
professional or personal what is the
toughest thing you've ever had to go
through and how did you get through it
for both of you oh this is going to make
me cry go ahead are damn all-round
well I'm not worse but the hardest thing
for me I think at one point was had to
go through a divorce this is so sad my
children involved I mean it worked out
in the end we're still friends and we
communicate still but it's uh it was
tough and I and I guess I know it's it's
widespread in our industry I'm talking
about the film industry not just
animation and that you know with the
deadlines and the trying to get things
done and happen you know you end up with
seven-day week and 14-hour days that
you're not shunning but not getting home
in time for for the family evenings I
don't think I can talk about mine prefer
no he has to do with the same subject
also because I've married my life to the
Arts I grew up in a family of seven
seven children all of them have gone
their separate ways and and basically
don't talk to each other very much as so
it's it's very much a family that's kind
of shattered and spread apart and I've
chosen career in my life career over
marriage and family and so the toughest
thing for me to go through is the
loneliness that
Nathan's with just being married to art
that's it's hard it's really really hard
and there's no comfort there's no
there's no touch there's none of the
things that I think a lot of people go
through but I think it's actually fueled
a lot of the things I talk about in the
movies like certainly an American tale
talking about the reunion of the family
is very close to me I know if that's
like being lost from the family and then
hunting for them and then finding them
again that's the hope
and I know there's a lot of people that
feel that too so that's probably the
hardest thing I've had to work through
over the years but I've done it and I'm
a perfectly here don't cry I'm a
perfectly happy individual right now I
don't want you to feel bad for me I
don't need any pity I just need your
money so so we can get this picture to
happen and finally very last question
for both of you again whether
professionally or personally what is the
proudest thing that you've ever done
taking the risk to leave Disney and I
don't think a lot of people know this
but we were very gung-ho while we were
at Disney and loved being there loved
actually dawn had loved the name Walt
Disney since he saw Snow White when he
was four years old and so it was only
wanted to work at Disney and but when we
got there in the 70s it obviously wasn't
what it was when Dawn first started back
in 1955 Don said the words to our
production manager Disney when we
resigned we're going to go out there and
challenge you to do it and and make you
get better and in the end I think from
all we've heard from the fans out there
is we were able to do that in in the in
the 15 years of our independent times at
NIMH and americantale Land Before Time
all dogs go to heaven were all movies
that moved people and it moved Disney to
do better I can say the fact that when I
was just a kid maybe four maybe younger
I had a dream and the dream that I
wanted was inspired by you know Walt I
wanted to be able to work in the
animation world and I dreamed that maybe
one day maybe I could
even make my own pictures and I've had
the pleasure of having that dream come
true a lot of people live their whole
life and their dreams never really
happen and they have to settle but they
don't get a chance to really make their
dreams come true I've had that blessing
and I'm just really really really
pleased with that
not too many get that I can tell you on
behalf of me and so many fans out there
we are so pleased that you made it
happen too because I I really wasn't
mincing words and the reviews I did
saying that you really have made such a
huge impact and some phenomenal films
and just amazing moments that stay with
you from childhood into adulthood so
honestly thank you not only for just
coming onto doing this interview and
doing our silly jokes and our reviews
and stuff but thank you for leaving such
a huge impact not just on the artform
but on us as well hey well thank you
Doug you know I've always liked the name
Doug if I ever have a son don't hold
your breath
I think I'll name him Doug Doug thank
you so much it's been a real pleasure
yeah